joe biden has the kind of entry
that could easily sink an incoming
president
and on day one the pandemic is his
biggest burden
and the immediate future looks grim
the death toll will likely top 500 000
next month
the cases will continue to mount we
didn't get into this mess overnight
it's going to take months for us to turn
things around
he started that process with a burst of
executive orders
increasing vaccinations and testing and
tougher travel restrictions and we're
instituting now
a new measure for individuals flying
into the united states
from other countries in addition to
wearing masks
everyone flying to the united states
from another country
will need to test before they get on
that plane
before they depart and quarantine when
they arrive in america he's promised a
wartime effort with a hundred million
vaccine shots in a hundred days
and he's defensive about the ambition
this is what he said when he was asked
if that figure
is enough when i announced that you all
said it's not possible
come on give me a break man that's the
question good start 100 million
[Music]
but the pressure is on the virus
spreading in most states
and uncertainty about whether
republicans will help him pass
a 1.9 trillion dollar covered response
package
biden does though have the faith of dr
fauci
back in the fold and with some
refreshing frankness
well you know one of the new things in
this administration is if you don't know
the answer don't guess
just say you don't know the answer the
idea that you can get up here
and talk about what you know what the
evidence
what the science is and know that's it
let the science speak
it is somewhat of a liberating feeling
that gives him space to reveal important
new detail including that the uk strain
is in 20 states
a white house that became hostile to his
research
is now happy to share it but listening
to the science
is only first base in the battle cordial
sky news washington